everyone seems to be adjusting to his
new role fashion designer Stella
McCartney who shares his passion for the
environment just one of hundreds invited
the palace yeah beautiful day to save
the planet
the king seemed less Keen to be
overheard a sign of how controversial
it's been that he's not going to cop 27
despite years of warning about the need
to act instead he left his prime
minister to speak if we do not act today
we will risk leaving an Ever more
desperate inheritance for our children
tomorrow
the reception was the king's chance to
bring together business
figures after reports that Liz truss had
told him not to go to Egypt reports
denied by the palace Jonathan porritt
has advised the King on environmental
issues and says it is a big Miss it's a
shame not to have had
King Charles there to represent this
whole approach to what we stand for it's
good that Richard sunak is our prime
minister at long last got his head
screwed on tight enough to understand
the significance of being there in
charmele Sheikh but let's be honest he
doesn't really understand the issues he
certainly doesn't understand the climate
diplomacy associated with it even with
the suggestions now that Rishi sunak may
have potentially advised the king to go
this has not been helpful for either
number 10 or the palace because at a
time where we've seen a change of prime
ministers and the start of a new Reign
they know they need to be seen to be
working together especially on such a
key Global issue
last year at cop26 the UK government put
him Center Stage we have to put
ourselves
on what might be called a war-like
footing but his friend and biographer
Jonathan dimbleby told me he's always
been aware that he'd have to change tack
what he had then was the freedom because
he had no constitutional position to
articulate his very strong and highly
informed views now as Monarch he can't
do that the palace insist he isn't
frustrated about not attending cop but
after 50 years of environmental
campaigning you would think that
remaining publicly mute may be a
challenge Rhiannon Mills Sky News at
Buckingham Palace